[Music]
the pace of the show is gonna probably
keep you in your seat throughout I'm not
sure there's a good time to get up the
executive producer of this year's VMAs
teasing Sunday's show to ET but what
about those rumors Taylor Swift will hit
the stage with host Harry not so far no
no and that's not happening as far as we
certainly seeing all the rumors flying
around but no that's that's not
happening good Taylor take the stage
solo right now there's there's nothing
happening right now so there's you know
the we certainly are aware of all the
rumors flying around but wouldn't that
be great but now we're not quite sure we
believe that but regardless Garret
promises and epic nights we've got a
fantastic first act with multiple
performances and and of course Katie and
the rest of it happening all the type of
show she's been lovely and we're having
a fantastic week putting it all together
with her there's gonna be I'm sure a lot
of costume changes in a lot of a lot of
movement I think one of the things about
this show is that the entire space is
dynamic I think Katie's really looking I
trying to use that space and really fun
and exciting way and she's you know
she's she is fun and dynamic and kinetic
personality so she's gonna be all over
the space and her performance will be
will be usual Katy Perry epicness